prochaine épreuve va vous forcer à mieux
vous connaître et à vivre ensemble et je
pense qu'à partir de l'épisode 5
véritablement ça commence à partir en
couille avec le talent de show
pas le talentueux c'est lé show était
débile
talents de show sur une île
c'était quelque chose
ce truc de rencontres à ce moment-là de
devoir jouer en binôme c'était grandiose
à là on est sur la scène du talent de
show c'est l'épreuve du jour c'est
chacun doit montrer son talent devant un
jury de le star et voilà tout on a fait
son petit spectacle
magie d'internet bien on a fait un truc
tout pourri un tour de magie avec mark
en fait c'est plus un spectacle de danse
au final qu'à spectacle d'hommage voit
et ça pour le coup c'est c'est un procès
bien dans la boîte
[Musique]
alors ça tu le dis pas marque cadum le
fonds l'a fait à prix jean même qu'on
sait pas assez vous y mon
truc quoi
moi je suis avec le personnage de laura
refait le point qui a indiqué un des
personnages qui me fait le plus rire
honnêtement et
actions c'était un choc d'un très grand
moment puisque j'ai totalement fait des
roulades avec à des leaders populistes
je pense que je peux cochet ça sur ma
liste m dolist elle apprend et que moi
faire des galipettes elle jongle avec
des bananes elle est jolie enfin c'est
vraiment deux personnalités tranche qui
se retrouvent donc franchement on a trop
volés
sont à jongler des bananes qui
malheureusement était trop mûres donc on
s'en fout les partout enfin c'était
hyper joyeux quoi action
[Applaudissements]
j'aime bien qui se souvient de rien
il est 18 heures c'est l'heure de
l'apéro j'ai ma petite idée moi je suis
en couple avec le personnage de kad
merad et du coup on se retrouve à faire
pardon pour les gens qui en font
vraiment dans la vie mais ce mini pièces
de théâtre
comme il n'ya pas fils où je vais écrire
une pièce sur le nôtre notre amitié un
peu forte et donc on va jouer une pièce
de théâtre un peu façon théâtre de
boulevard c'est un moment drôle je crois
et j'espère 13 ans beaucoup rigolé
contre l'a fait et fait pas tache au
jour avec les poches les parents ça fait
du bien c'est pathétique
c'est pathétique c'est on peut pas plus
nulle a en fait
moi j'étais donc en duo avec alexandra
et alex étant très très affûté sur tout
ce qui est armes on s'est dit que
c'était très bien de jouer à ce qu'on
appelle la cime humaine dans ses
couteaux
les enfants marco pappa pas des yeux
là l'expression tombe à merveille c'est
quand même un poil de cul
effectivement c'est là où on va se
rendre compte qu hervé à à une
suppression n'a que ça à mon tour plus
tôt un plus en l'occurrence pour cette
scène pour cette séquence sait qu en lui
envoyant le couteau bien entre les
jambes ne me sens rien
faire puisque pour faire partie de la
communauté des enfants de
saint-jean-de-luz passé trente ans on
doit plus procréer donc on nous joue
sectionne tout organe reproducteur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors je vous dis à à jouer c'est assez
marrant mais moi tout ce qui est
manipulation d'armes ça me fait un peu
peur
donc j'ai bien dit à partir du moment où
alex donc là il a un couteau en main je
ne suis pas dans le champ je ne suis pas
sûr plateau langer une peur j'ai une
peur bleue des armes
bush la caméra
pour montage bien fondus enchaînés
c'est spécial c'est un cinéma et la
ferme les yeux et
ballon je suis tellement chaud c'était
faire de la grosse connerie c'est quoi
la morale des choses c'est qu'il faut
garder nos vrais c'était une journée je
me souviens en sort on s'est dit on est
vraiment chez les fous ce jour là
[Applaudissements]
avec tous ces petits shows et puis
surtout ce jury
incroyable
on à vincent macaigne qe2 qui joue ludo
leur csdr de la saison i like your magic
udo qu'est devenu magicien entre-temps
biaggi mots qui s'appelle illarine au
mont aciéries
et on a lionel boutboul la star de la
chanson française et balou
et pour la petite histoire on avait
toujours essayer de trouver un chanteur
pour faire ce personnage un vrai
chanteur
[Musique]
et puis au final on se dit maintenant on
a un chanteur né qui est dans l'équipe
et qui est un super acteur télé jean
toussaint est là pour ça comme
d'habitude il s'entendait vraiment mais
toi tu chantes en fait
je venais faire un karaoké juste avant
bien sûr
pas possible sinon c'est mon frère
découvre mon frère qui revient qui
revient voilà qui débarque j'avais pas
vu depuis des années et je me dis qui va
de nouveau prendre la lumière est
effectivement il se met à chanter à ma
place et c'est le cauchemar le cauchemar
est le cauchemar
et au final je dis je vais chanter quand
même et je vais vous prouver que filmer
les âges de tous égaux aux 83 membres du
jury je suis le meilleur et je chante
bien quand on dit qu'un mais on est
mieux quand on était à table avec eux
tama véhicules billets
moi je suis son homme-orchestre a
finalement son band je suis son groupe à
moi tout seul
puisque je suis un beatboxer de peu de
talent en renfort double donner un petit
tuto pour les personnes qui meurent à
apprendre à faire ce qu'ils peuvent
faire une boîte et est comme ça et verts
qui moule et le vert avec une sorte de
petit graves
et plus
voilà de quoi cette scène elle est drôle
parce que parce qu'elle est en plus elle
change de toutes les autres scènes s'est
d'un coup je deviens très timide
beaucoup moins colérique et jeux et
chants très très mal donc c'est un peu
un peu en creux pourra comme ça donc je
vois j'ai bien aimé faire ça de chanter
comme le comme une merde
choix très très mal mais étonnamment
c'est moi qui n'aime vivant l'épreuve je
la trouve exceptionnel règne des gens là
en la filmant jc il a en ce moment
franchement on est chez les fous
on a trouvé des geeks très très drôle
pour tout le monde
franchement ça a été un grand moment de
créer un grand moment de créer en live
[Musique]